today we're looking at John Stuart Mill
and Mill that's coming after Bentham I
want to give you just a little bit of
background about their relation to each
other is that fits in with the first
part what we're looking at today
so John Stuart Mill is John Mills son
there are two philosophers John Stuart
Bell the son John mental the father and
John mill was a friend of it Jeremy
Bentham and John Bell actually decided
to incorporate that into his parenting
style and the family life so John Stuart
Mill is like the first generation after
Bentham being raised in a utilitarian
household and he you know like a lot of
people coming in the second wave of a
movement he's doing something a little
bit different than the first way to do
the first wave of any given movement of
ideas they come up with the ideas right
time a they want to fit everything into
those ideas and quite often they they
attract a lot of attention Bentham tried
to reform the British legal system he
had some some effect on it some of them
good some of them depending on how you
view phenology and the development of
prisons perhaps not quite so good but
overall good and utilitarianism came on
the scene and now it's a legitimate
moral philosophy it's sort of brought
together a lot of different kinds of
ways of thinking that we're out there at
the time but nobody had given a name to
it sort of like Tom you know you know
when a new political party arises or a
new movement in music or art arises what
happens is there's already stuff going
on and then somebody comes up with a
name and a couple
but now everybody can fit into it what
happens in the second step after that
usually people start raising criticisms
and his way of trying to deal with all
the possible criticisms this is part of
what makes them a little bit boring to
read I think all of you found is come up
with a numerous of lists you know one
two three to cover everything right
that's one way to do it it's not the
most interesting way to do it and
sometimes you end up in variably leaving
something out and you might not be
entirely satisfied with middle is coming
after him and middle can you actually
see all the criticisms coming up around
he's living this out and so he's a
little bit better situated to make some
improvements on utilitarianism and the
most important improvement he makes is
that shift away from quantitative just
calculate the pleasures and pains
uncertain even basis like something with
the balance sheet to also incorporating
qualitative distinctions between the
pains and pleasures
another thing that he's going to do is
he's going to respond to this is he
doesn't sin other places besides
totalitarianism he's going to respond to
some of the major criticisms that are
being made and utilitarian theory I put
those up here on the board the ones that
are in chapters 1 & 2 materials but
before we do that I want to talk a
little bit about why he thinks this is
important to do so we've looked at how
many different authors about five or six
major moral theories as far in the
semester you notice they talk about a
lot of the same stuff on that and with
those application assignments you've
figured out they're not all going to see
a situation the same way they emphasize
different parts of the situation and
somebody who's following a virtue ethics
moral theory may not decide something
the same way that somebody who's a pure
egoist would do right now moral theories
not only have to be able to tell us what
to do they also have to be able to
account for why people do the things
they do how they develop towards the
good how they want to arrange their
lives what they want to be balloting
what they want sacrificing and one of
the things they have to be able to do in
order to carry that out is to address
other people or theorists and to address
the criticisms that people make well I
have an analogy here for you think of
every one of your majors that you're
studying you are learning a craft you're
learning a discipline and sooner or
later you're actually going
to exercise some sort of leadership
Aventis right now you're in the learning
process right so this is actually I know
you don't realize this at the time of
this is actually the fun part once you
get done and you're actually out there
practicing your craft you have to make
the case for what it is that you propose
so if you're in a business you're going
to be in meetings where the bosses
called you in and wants to know three or
four different ways of looking at the
situation and what ought to be done in
order to market this product or should
this company mean for harsh decisions
making and you're gonna have to write a
report and you have to come up with this
if you're a historian you're gonna have
to propose a history of something a
narrative and there's going to be other
people out there who are writing on the
same thing and not coming to the same
conclusions if you're you know in the
arts you're gonna have to struggle
against other artists and you're gonna
have to make a case for why you should
get grant money or why somebody should
buy your stuff somebody else's you just
go on and on and on enough this is a
common experience that you're gonna have
now if you're going to say that your
proposal is the best one there's a
couple ways to do this right so imagine
a playing field now you've got say five
competitors and you're one you all want
the same thing you've all want to get
the seal of approval how do you make
your case or think about another going
into a job and you're one of the last
five people you sent in your Vita or
your resume there were 300 applicants
200 got thrown out right away you made
it to the larger pool and then that kind
of boiled down to an even smaller pool
of maybe 20 applicants and they did
initial interviews by Skype or something
like that you know all the people now
it's you and five other people or you
and four other you know those other
people you're actually competing in the
same field you've never acted with them
before you know what their strengths are
what their weaknesses are you know what
they're likely to say in the interview
how do you how do you ensure that you're
going to get the job what do you have to
do
yeah well basically whatever their eyes
are you want to make sure that these
have them or are stronger where they're
weaker ideal so you don't hype up where
you're basically stronger and maybe
potentially downplay their strengths
their weaknesses not directly in the
interview but highlighted more so your
strengths and why they're more important
than something else made potential yeah
it depends on the field of management so
it's legitimate to say you don't wanna
go I can do this just as good as he can
right some other cases make your time
but you're right you you have to not
only put your own strengths for people
you know when I ask these questions and
I've asked this in other formats people
say well you've got to put you know you
got to highlight your own strengths your
own your qualities that's good but
they're doing that too
I mean by the time that you get to the
final five everybody's got some so I'm
Taylor
everybody's got something to put on the
table that's not enough to actually get
you where you need to go you can also
just you know cut down on them and say
guys it's wrong you know this one has
affairs of your office this one's on
Facebook all the time you know you can
do that but that's probably not going to
be very effective this sort of ad
hominem they call them attacks if you
really want to make your case you have
to do exactly what you just said we have
to say well here's a strength that they
have and it doesn't look like I have
that strength but I really do you know
then I might my resume I know that they
have more years of experience in this
field but if you actually look at my
resume more carefully you'll see that I
did
[ __ ] than that my internship was at the
top firm in that field so I probably
should count more that would be a way to
ensure that you're actually at the job
where were you have to do reports and
you're you know other people argue
against you're gonna say yeah I know
they made these points but my theory or
my view can actually account for all
those points and I also have this so
that's what John Stuart Mill's doing
this utilitarian is he is in effect
saying utilitarianism can address any of
the things that are right and the other
moral theories it can incorporate them
that can show that we've actually got
them and then we've also got more for an
example of a moral theory that doesn't
do this very well think about the might
makes right velocity or thing about
emotivism one reason why it motive isn't
isn't a very good moral theory because
at bottom if you're an emotivist
everything boils down to because I said
so or because I feel that way so if you
have a motive ax stand in virtue
ethicist and the virtue ethicist says
you know you really ought to be
cultivating these these traits of
character that we call virtues and it
requires sacrifices on your part
the emotivist will say something like
yeah I mean if you're into that sort of
thing that that's review but not
everybody's into that and other things
are for them is that very satisfying
treatment of this this concept of virtue
virtues would just be things that you
happen to be into things
you know this turns you on the idea of
being a just person you like that so
yeah go ahead to be a just person is I'm
actually going to make you a just person
is that an adequate understanding of
justice or say courage or moderation
probably not or if you're the might
makes right philosophy how would they
make us a temperance Wow
temperance with moderation if somebody
makes you do it then that's the right
thing to do if they order you that to be
temperate then that's the right thing to
do but otherwise there's really no value
to it what does that adequately capture
this is one of the test for moral
theorists that's why utilitarianism is
one of the big contenders because it can
actually address the other theories so
let's look at these criticisms Bentham
sent him to stop a very emphatic ways
this could lead to misunderstandings at
times one of them doesn't really have
anything to do with them and he starts
off with this and this is an interesting
one to think about especially for our
culture there's actually a line of
clothing out there called well I came
across when I was doing a little web
search yeah they do have stuff that is
fairly good to latarian at least in one
sense when you use the word utilitarian
and you're not talking about moral
theory you're just using it as an
adjective very often it has the
connotation of being stuff that's just
useable and doesn't really have any
attractiveness to it
enjoying it to it or pleasantness to it
and I've got a great example right here
I've got a prop this is reasonable doors
closed is because I took the doorstop
and this doorstop is not particularly
attractive isn't it
this is a purely utilitarian thing in
that sense of the term I mean look at
you know the wood is pitted it was made
out of cheap cheap longer to begin with
where the person couldn't they didn't do
a very good job with not scoring it
it's got chips out of it there's like a
little bit of paint in there is this
something that if you have a nice you
know attractive home you want sitting at
home unless you're being kind of ironic
probably not right
are there ways this could be improved to
make it more attractive maybe paint it
all on one color or sand and then
varnish it nicely but does it do the
same job this works pretty good though
this works just as good as if it was
painted whenever your favorite colors
with your very high grade of paint or
it'll be carved pastoral scene on the
side it is a deep purpose and as soon as
the purpose just fine utilitarian
clothing or utilitarian architecture or
stuff like that would mean architecture
that it works but it's not particularly
pleasing to the eye for to the other
senses is that what utilitarianism as a
moral theory what you know is that what
it's putting forth this an idea
what do you create pleasure you looking
for things for what they their uses but
their use in terms of how much pleasure
exam goes yeah that's very good now if
it was down to something like you know
we can feed a hundred people really
boring food or we can only feed one
person's really really great food
Bentham would say well you know the pain
that you're preventing by feeding them
the boring food is not weighing the
pleasure of one person but if you can
feed a hundred people and not feed them
boring food
that's better than there's no there's
nothing good about boring food there's
nothing good about great buildings
there's nothing good intrinsically about
simple doorstops if you can make things
better more likely to produce pleasure
it's a yeah so this is not really a
valid objection and then he knows mill
goes up or together extreme now so if we
know that it actually is about pain and
pleasure some people say well that's a
bad point about utilitarianism and any
can't even ISM and think about you know
when we use the word humanism we don't
usually use it as a word of praise in
our society doing we talk about somebody
being hedonistic we mean that as a
criticism we mean that all they care
about is pleasure and generally we mean
all they care about is immediate sensual
pleasure you know that's all they focus
on so they'll do anything to get there
one way to express this is to say that
utilitarianism like other forms of
hedonism is a philosophy fit for pigs
pigs have a lot of pleasure okay
they'll eat just about anything you can
put in front of them some gruesome
things and we'll tell you about stories
about pig farmers some of the things
pigs eat and they seem to like it and
pigs they like the way oh come on roll
around and you know we know that's
because they don't and they like
physical activity running around bumping
into each other they're actually a wild
form even aggressive
why are they there because they like it
they enjoy that they like all of the
things that other animals like and we
like those things to know me I mean if
you were a hedonist like Arastoo puss
then what would you pursue given as much
you know pleasures of taste and sends
and wearing clothes that feel good to
you or look good to you and going to the
shows or the movies or whatever as much
as you can get it as much sex as you
possibly can hopefully without any you
know commitments that might produce any
sort of problems for you sleep in
whenever you want to don't commit
yourself to any big projects that are
going to take away from your pleasures
because you know this is the good life
yeah I guess would fit into that but did
Epicurus fit that bill didn't he
distinguish between higher and lower
pleasures mental pleasures and physical
borders if you can make that distinction
that's what we're going to focus on a
little bit later that addresses that
problem you can say we have like that
what do we roll around in on massage
tables on tanning beds we like to sleep
warm blankets that sort of thing like to
bask in the Sun those are all physical
pleasures right and utilitarianism can
recognize it those are good but it
doesn't just stay with those does it
there's other kinds of pleasures let's
go to the next one now this is a
different kind of objection there are
other moral theories out there we're
gonna look at one the body will cont
starting next week let's say that
happiness really should be the goal if
you want to talk about right and wrong
morally good and bad that you don't
focus on pleasure and happiness you
focus on some other things like safe
duty or a virtue and you know the things
that often times in real life require us
to sacrifice our little share of
happiness or pleasure you know if you
think about this if you get married
because I think many
and to eventually you live you know ten
years with your spouse and you're having
a great time and suddenly they come down
sort of not only terminal but
debilitating disease are you gonna stay
with them knowing that who they are
are now going to slowly disappear maybe
they've never really onset Alzheimer's
or they've got MS or they're in a
terrible car accident who's they become
paraplegic you're going to lose out on a
lot of others are you going to stick
with them and say I made a commitment
even though I'm not having much fun I'm
going to sacrifice my own happiness to
my duty what are you gonna do and say
you know good times are over
see you later well mill would say why
does the person prefer duty or state
version right do you want to be virtuous
do you want to be courageous what you
have to do have to stand up to fears is
that fun probably not that's why you're
afraid of this talk right that's why you
haven't done it up to this point if
you're choosing to do that what's
motivate compensative the purity of duty
but isn't there a kind of higher
pleasure or happiness
action that comes with doing the right
thing if that really motivates if you
are willing to sacrifice your happiness
in one respect for doing the right thing
being motivated well yeah and it may
also end up being the condition for good
consequences later it's easier to stand
up to the bully the next time but you
guys will all probably experiences in
public speaking when I first started
teaching I was really nervous every time
before
to lecture for about a year now
you know if somebody wants me to give a
lecture I don't have any fear about that
anymore so I know what to expect but
they did have one time and not even that
fear is a good consequence it allows me
to actually enjoy it so I need of you
that I have to do this sort of thing for
a living the next one utilitarianism
could make us cold and not sympathizing
or uncaring about other people
individually so maybe the utilitarian
because they look at a society or the
community as a whole they look at what's
good for everyone but they're not really
that interested in what is good for her
or what's good for her or what's good
for him maybe things like personal
relationships don't matter that much to
you Terry and within that epidemic maybe
here's an example there are some
professors who say things like I teach
to my class as a whole I don't actually
want to get to know the students because
then you know there might be favoritism
you know we're gonna be the next class
around I don't want to get too attached
to them myself
and besides I've got too many damn
students anyway to keep their names
straight or things like that professors
say things like that I'm just going to
teach to the class as a whole you know
they get something out of it that's
great but you know as individuals they
don't really matter now if I act like
that if say you come to my office hours
and you sit down and you start talking
with me and you say something the
students are you have students all the
time every semester you come in and say
I'm really struggling with the material
I don't really this isn't really my cup
of tea I'm not really that into this
sort of stuff and they're making you
know sort of an honest professional
showing me who they are
take some guts right what if I respond
to them and I say it would be interested
as a student I don't meet them as a
person how did they make them together
let's say you're coming and I say
something like wow you gotta just get
with the program teach the class as a
whole how would you feel worse yeah
it's discouraging it's painful and
that's worth mill says personal
relationships are employed
you know the society as a whole is
important but why because the society is
composed of this person this person this
person this person it's not as if
there's anything like society or the
community out there all by itself it's
an aggregate of people so loving your
family and behaving in a loving way
within your family would be a good thing
for utilitarian having friendship
relations you know that that develop
over time that would be a good thing it
goes against basic human instinct which
is
visual survival if it comes down to it
my group right well yeah pretty much
like if it comes down to it let's say
you're on a train track so that was
another person that you're both tied
down you pull a lever it's gonna kill
the other person errors gonna kill you
two or five other people you're most
likely at that moment if you only have
like two seconds to think about it too
big you're pulling that lead and that's
not a condition right
I don't know I mean I I think it's just
instinct that like I want to survive
like I know and the mill no actually
Bentham those type of us what would
build us more says that until utility
utilitarians utilitarianism it's sort of
reworked the way in which we think about
things through moral education and
conditioning we're not going to be the
kind of people that will typically favor
that one actually reminds me the old
joke I think you guys prove this there's
two guys out camping and there comes
charging them and the first guy starts
putting on running shoes the second game
is what the hell are you do it you know
the bear cannot run us it doesn't matter
if you put up running shoes or not it's
still gonna eat us there
I jumped on you so you stand replacing
together guy you know for his own
selfish interests that's sort of like I
think you're right but the mill and
Bentham would see that is just a sign of
how we need to change the way in which
we educate the question has become them
can you ever really get rid of that yeah
that's probably a bigger question
here novelists have tried to do any of
ever read brave new world by Huxley or
Walden - with the along most sort of
lines there's other examples in this
where somebody they think tries to see
what utilitarianism might look like if
it was put into the whole of society if
we thought of everything in terms of
pains and pleasures let's go on with the
other one this is going to be an
important one not this class session the
next class session when we look at
justice and lights and stuff like that
remember the example that I brought up
before if we could pick out one person
in class produce a lot of displeasure
for them but it produced a lot of
pleasure for us at the Japanese game
show example that would be okay from the
utilitarian perspective even if we did
terrible degrading humiliating things to
that person and violated that was a
person violated their human dignity well
note says it's not quite so simple
because if you were going to do that
thing yeah in the immediate situation
that could produce more pleasure than
pain but if you did that and you made a
practice of that how did that affect
society overall wouldn't that lead to
more pain overall than pleasure knowing
that we're the kind of people who
indulge in that sort of thing would that
affect us wouldn't the fact that maybe
somebody else
do that to you or to those that you care
about produce some at least worry or
anxiety in your mind that might in you
know taint the pleasure that you're
feeling and watching the other person be
elated or later we're gonna put that one
because now we want to come back to this
this issue of all pleasures and pains
what determines whether pain or a
pleasure is of higher quality not just
quantity but good quality
put everything on the same level
you thought you could calculate
everything against everything else so
this works for some things like candy
bars - candy - candy bars they're the
same kind of candy bar it's pretty much
twice as good as one candy bar right
we're thinking about money
if you give me a 20 say have any change
for a 20 and I say give me two fives is
that gonna work
you'd be a sucker to take that look Jim
and if I were to say I'll give you a
twenty third for two fives you would
take that deal if I said that guy's a
sucker because I'm not realizing that
those are measurable and could you trade
off to prevent appeals against each
other like oh when you swap things with
each other yeah you're right that's a
with us what's the action figures
and Barbara's to be actually still
plenty marvelous back on the training
carrots training carrots right I don't
know if people still do that as kids we
have like baseball cards and hockey
cards and then there were Star Wars
cards and I'll give you one of these if
you give me these things fine why do you
do that is your gonna get a same amount
of pleasure are there qualitative
differences are there cases where one
pleasure is a higher pleasure one's a
lower and no amount of the lower
pleasure would be enough to make up for
that higher pleasure know thinks there
are so you know think about candy bars
know you don't like any bars right
anybody ever doesn't like a candy bar
probably like different candy bars but
let's say we could get an assortment
pack right there was a comedian yeah you
know was the comedy skit
I think I'm mad tv a long time ago you
remember you know those Klondike bars
what would you do for a Klondike bar
well what would you do for a Klondike
bar there are some things that are
getting fairly simple like I'd go to a
complete stranger and say I love
Klondike okay so I would be a little
embarrassing for me but I've a trade-off
that that that pain for the pleasure of
the Klondike bar right now this comedy
skit was you know what are you killing
me in for a Klondike bar
and you know get it go along with the
premise a little bit this person really
really likes Klondike bars and they say
no I think I what
they have like their hands are all
bloody and all that now we're eating the
Klondike alright they look at sort of is
if they're doing this ecstatic
experience what do you know that's
that's a comedy skit and we laugh at it
because it's so far-fetched because even
a whole case of Klondike bars isn't
going to for utilitarian just by killing
some war I think about certain degrading
things would you other things we find
humiliating would you allow somebody to
go through this is assuming that you've
actually got something to hide which
might indicate would you allow somebody
to go through every document out there
about you that exists
would you go would you go I mean if you
don't have anything behind it's a great
thing it's got yourself a lifetime
supply if you have to think about it
here's what you're thinking about I
don't know that that is a qualitatively
different kind of King no amount of this
is actually going to make up for this
world let's say we you know we say
something like this you're gonna go to a
desert island all you like hot chocolate
right is there anybody who doesn't like
chocolate as we need a beer as an
example before but not everybody likes
beer it's a hot truck
how many do you really like come try
something what do you like you guys I
like coffee drink so you can go to
Starbucks okay so you're gonna go to a
desert island and it's sort of like you
know a reality TV show so there's
something you don't actually have to
worry about food or animals attacking
you or getting dysentery or malaria or
shark attacks and no surprise but you're
going to be there for five years
now you have a choice to make
here's here's what they they would you
like they have an unlimited supply all
the Starbucks drinks the whole thing
even given the holiday dress whenever
you want
and anytime you want and they're all
made you know well all the time or would
you be a would you rather be allowed to
bring a blackberry how many of you take
the library does anybody would take the
Starbucks you will
okay now why would you take the library
those people would take the libraries of
the star busters why would you take the
little library I mean you can only drink
coffee so then you start building at
least the high collar answer it starts
getting boring
you got a whole library you can read
like different stories you can kind of
like escape in your reading from the
place where you're at anything about
you're in desert there's not a whole lot
to City so reading kind of gets the
imagination going - yeah so it's more of
a mental pleasure I would say rather
than a physical one there's a wider
range like you pointed out there's only
so much you to do with coffee drink I
worked as a barista actually for a lot
of clothes in the culpers I experimented
with just about anything you could you
could do some waffle thanks to doing
some syrups you shouldn't mix together
but after a while you're right and if
you get kicked out of water with that
there's only so much you can do and
that's not to say that if you can't have
Starbucks unlimited the rest your life
that that wouldn't be able to think from
the utilitarian perspective go
well this would be like an outdoor kiosk
or something I mean you assume you've
got a little hot and you could read in
the hotter you take a coffee no hi
what's up was it desert I you're doing
the desert island it's a question of
whether you go to the Starbucks or for
the library which you notice it's a
forced choice you have to choose one why
don't you choose the Starbucks does you
love Starbucks so much that you get in
so much clutter around okay now another
thing that you said is really important
books appeal to our imagination they
engage our higher faculties I'm going to
actually say to that's a certain extent
Mill might be a little bit too crude in
this and that Starbucks drinks and
certain kinds of foods could actually
appeal to our higher faculties as well
in certain planets but not to the degree
that books yeah I mean I love iced tea
but I think I would just like it say we
changed it up and it was iced tea
instead of Starbucks okay I think I'd
still to the library so I would just get
so bored even if he ended like man go to
the pH and yeah
green tea versus white tea or something
yeah it's great but it's just either way
well that's there's something to them
and you can you can say the same thing
about any of the basic physical
pleasures that we tend to share with the
animals there's only so much you can do
with food there's a probably a wider
range because you're gonna have so many
things but even that there's only so
many ways to make a hamburger cheese on
it but eventually with what's maybe you
can't on other things but nobody's
actually found that
well so you get the basic idea there
there are higher pleasures and what mill
calls an ideal judge is somebody that
knows inside and out both pleasures so
you would have to have somebody who
actually really does like Starbucks if
you don't like Starbucks that is there's
no useful question there that's part of
why I didn't use beer - some people
don't like beer I haven't liked it just
actually prove myself but it doesn't
appeal to you you can't be a good judge
for that also if you don't fully
appreciate you know reading books you
wouldn't be a good judge of the pleasure
of reading laws or let's say the
pleasure was watching football on
television if you don't get into
football on television because that just
never appealed to you you're not really
a good judge of where that fits in the
hierarchy of pleasures you have to be
somebody who's actually experienced
those pleasures and Mill says that a
person who has actually experienced both
of these pleasures you know reasonably
well will will invariably choose the
higher pleasure over the lower pleasure
why because the higher pleasure he
actually is a better pleasure it offers
us more pleasure on a different level
than the lower pleasure does and it
appeals to what's distinctively human
about us so let's think about some of
our our different pleasures we
experience
this would be a good place actually to
ask you this this winter
what are some of the experiences that
you've had could be recently to be in
the past or some of the things that you
you know of practices things like that
that give you a lot of pleasure that are
that are very enjoyable to you
the game none of you you know put down
like best meal of my life you know that
doesn't come to your mind as the
greatest pleasure you know when you were
kids you've probably would have said
something like candy or french fries
maybe McDonald's french fries are a lot
better when they're actually cooked beef
grease movies going to the movies going
to the amusement park
not just the roller coaster but the
whole amusement park kids like watching
cartoons or at Disney shows
okay so we have all these these sorts of
things what makes some fun
whatever-whatever reading actually what
are the components why is it going to
the gym to get a six-pack or any other
people six-packs other people's bodies
even younger than you guys are now I
used to date I was a director side of
dude medium weight high reps high
amounts of sets
I had these workouts that I would do
like three hours a day every day and I
would go to the why they do it because
why was the serious place to lift
weights in the town and it was really
interesting because a lot of the guys
that were there that I was learning in
that from they never really built right
and they would do their serious workout
at the Y and there was only there's only
one woman who also did the weight
training in that room and she was a
female bodybuilder and she was you know
she wasn't like the super you know
gigantic once she was like really trim
really strong she was actually one of
the trainers now what was interesting as
a lot of these guys after they would do
their real workout then they go to pick
was a big candy used to be called anyway
it's just think of these gems where it's
a very nice in the gym and mirrors all
around and people go there kind of
socialize and why would they go there so
show off pick up girls they wouldn't
actually do a real workout they're
theirs
she's up next to some of these sort of
chatting and they women have gotten that
way by doing that sort of practice they
got that way by actually exercising and
they were doing it as a means to an end
to try to pick up dates so that every
day we're going there because they like
looking at people some of the women who
went there they would go and they'd like
put on makeup work out saying yeah yeah
there's like in this area there's this
specific gym exactly like what this
thing so it's so funny because I'm a
real room that goes down I'll go there
sometimes I'm going there to work out
I'm like you see all these girls are
like dressed up their eras all done I'm
like it's gonna get ruined in like 15
minutes but no
sometimes it feels good to do some
physical activity like some people like
to lift weights with people like the bag
other people like to wrong because it
helps them deal with the stresses of
their day that would be less maybe the
direct pleasure or more getting rid of
the pain you know pretty solitary it's
getting rid of pain mildly depressed
maybe the antidepressants aren't the way
to go and exercise but you're right yeah
physically there are certain things you
know there's a lot of things that that
tap into the pleasure centers apart a
great that's why drugs are so
pleasurable right there Tianna
actually can become addictive because
tanning also you know hits those
pleasure centers some people get hooked
on that because it feels so good to do
my back surgery over winter break so I
haven't done any exercises since winter
break and then I just I can remember
from when I used to exercise how am I
because it just makes you so less stress
for you here you're right yeah
so there are a lot of different good
good things about the gym and exercising
maybe they're also socializing you get
to know some of the people where you go
work out with somebody know there's some
painful things I mean if you're lifting
weights you're actually hurting yourself
right it doesn't hurt you're not gonna
get what they say no pain no gain
we were training that off for all these
these these good things and now notice
do you feel the animals going to the gym
and some distinctively human thing
animals do exercise and they do actually
take enjoyment physical activity
the art Wow they run around jump on each
other and bite each other and then go
bark over here and if I throw a stick
they they go chase the stick and then
want me with it because they want me to
chase them around they love that we
enjoy physical exercise - don't worry
about whether they're fed too big to
worry about whether they're do they have
self-esteem issues oh we do I mean
humans Oh like we never actually needed
to exercise per se like to have a
specific set place to go until we pretty
much got that job
yeah what it is I realized that like I
used to work on campus and like fixing
computers I have to carry computers
around campus and so forth and then I
got a desk job and like immediately I
gave my 20 pounds like right away it's
like the worst thing ever like I you
know I didn't have exercise it could be
anything I wanted to
except that kept eating everything I
wanted let me into it I went for a run
from biking everywhere to having a car
and began teaching that's spending a lot
of time sitting but you know we did
human beings did also realize that if we
want to do certain things it helps to do
certain kinds of exercise if you want to
go fight the animals we should probably
bulk up so we do that other animals
don't do that they certainly don't tie
it in their self-image I mean they may
have
get upset because the other dog contest
or something
yeah they accept them there might be
something to the distressing animals
exercise anything stress socializing I
mean it really depends on how are
socialized errand are sort of the animal
ways of socializing is nice just to be
nice to other people do that too though
we talk with each other so there's an
adrenaline rush that comes with it
probably familiar with that we like
doing things that we feel are kind of
scary but not truly scary if the roller
coaster we suddenly think that it's it
actually is in reality on safe that was
a whole different ride and we're gonna
longer experience with pleasure right
never experiencing anxiety I played like
big football games and stuff like that I
don't think anything comes close
now locos there's a basement yeah that
could be I'm really it's the whole idea
of you're like literally risking your
life but you're making it yeah and
that's what makes it so much better
like I used to write like sports legs
and you know do like tricks that I'm
never gonna do again because my arm went
like this after a while yeah like on my
arm but it's that whole idea of you
doing something that's risky that could
cause you to lose your life but you're
making it through and that's why that
adrenaline rush is so big and people
enjoy it
yeah that's why the kiddie roller
coaster doesn't I need to go to this
place at Marriott's Great America which
is no Six Flags Great America they have
one roller coaster called The Wizard
like the beginning roller coaster and I
had some spy roles and stuff like that
you didn't go upside down because when I
was a kid that was the big thing they
guess they were having trouble making
rollercoasters where it was you could
safely go upside down and then they came
out with some roller coasters where you
did go upside down and the first one was
of course just a big loop and my dad
and so we went on that and then Great
America came up with the demon that's
one actually that later on people did
get started yeah that one had not just
blues but actually like corkscrews right
you could tell how much if you're gonna
try to do this in a utilitarian way how
long would a person be willing to stand
in line cuz you could go on The Wizard
like five times for the amount of time
that it would take you to wait in line
before the demon the people with the
wizard was always empty because most
people wanted to go out on the demon and
then they came out with the American
Eagles all the little miracles are still
the largest wooden roller coaster in the
world and the winder that was a two
hours long but we waited in it because
we wanted to have that experience and we
felt that there was something better
about that than just going on the wizard
and if you actually know here's another
thing that gets more interesting you
know something about roller coasters if
you like research if you compare them
across each other that's again a more
distinctively human activity that's
involving your intellect and that can
make your pleasure
if you know something about the thing
you're taking closure again really like
Starbucks you can research coffee and
there's a whole world out there but why
this coffee has this space why this one
has that taste culinary is a great place
to do that right up the road that
improves your experience doesn't it when
you actually know something about why
this wine that you're tasting tastes the
way that it does and where it came from
why this roller coaster was put together
this way and why the bank has to come
here instead of over here that improves
your experience when you watch a
football show if you're
and you see the locking heads they're
talking students you know deconstructing
what what went right in the game and
what went wrong in the game if you don't
just trick them off and say shut up you
guys but you actually watched them and
then you watch the highlights and that
improves your experience it's because
that appeals to your intellect that
appeals is something distinctively human
about spending time in every channel
what is it you like about who had that
what ever spend time with your family
okay same familiar places being enough
sort of routine with them again you wake
up like Sunday morning they began mix
breakfast or something there's something
comforting about that animals have that
too is there a distinctively human
something about that your family
probably has some distinctive things
that you do that are not just purely
animal pleasures getting to know other
people yeah I think dogs get to know
each other on some level on cats do as
well but I think that we human beings
get to know each other have much deeper
levels what are you're succeeding at
that project that's fun of men to begin
right I have mentioned this before I
like to pass people when driving makes
impeccable experience to me but that's a
pretty low level kind of thing that's
just like I got I graduate
and there's the relief
that's going to go away really quick
what else there's a sense of
accomplishment for all of you and is it
possible for a pink dog Mouse to feel
that sort of sense of accomplishment or
even wrap its head I don't think so my
dog pitches she seems pretty happy that
she succeeded in getting yeah but is
that on the level of like having a
long-term project well they don't do as
much as we do
I feel like compared to what they
actually do what we actually do is kind
of on the same level like they they
worked a long way from what they paid to
do that right but so you'll do as much
as we do in the first place so they have
a different frame of reference I think
with us working on something to get it
like dogs are thinking I need to get
this right away oh great I got it okay
what now like put it with us yeah I
don't think yeah they're happy for that
moment but there's no real sense of
accomplishment you can we could go on a
hunting trip
that's do you might have memories trains
for years to be able to help a blind
person through their life maybe police
dog yeah works for many years to help
finally actually does graduate you're
right that those involved complex chests
and they have to take place over tiny
dog trainers when they want to get dogs
and this works for the horse trainers
and all that if you want to be really
successful with them you get them to do
things that they enjoy doing anyway
71,000 actually and you encourage them
in doing that
relax so you realize the potential of
him as much as a candy but it only goes
so far
millimoles point is we humans are much
less restricted and things that engage
our higher punters our ultimate our
higher faculties were ultimately much
more satisfied
what's something that you find very
enjoyable
yeah okay okay what else you say maybe
four or five examples yeah okay what
about sports doing them watching them
now I need something that's kind of
lower kind of pressure anything you like
yeah sleep this so now with each one of
these think about what you would be
willing to trade them off against what
you have to choose between them what you
would rank higher than it when you would
rank lower than so let's let's use yoga
so what's involved let's think about
that first because yoga can be just you
know watching a video and then doing
some of the postures in the class it can
mean Angela's studying the philosophy
behind it you know Papa John's sutras
there's a lot of different possibilities
it could mean - showing up and saying
namaste to people and walking out right
walking around with a yoga mat I know
pants what is it that people are
enjoying with you what makes it pleasure
it's your plight of yourself
yeah we'll start with that and we can
add more
okay it's physical exercise yes what
else anybody else have any other things
that get out of you know the components
to it that make it
anybody else do you
that's interesting
these dresses that's less a a pleasure
itself all they need to take pleasure in
that and more the removal of a paint or
the removal of something that leads to
onion what's all that stress drawing
okay that's interesting right there what
else do you like do drama
I don't like drunk so much because that
might drive your offices and see how bad
my penmanship is just imagine how
squiggly lines I placed it before my
answer so you
anybody else have anything yeah okay
something that you can step back and
look at or pass on to somebody else give
them a pleasure through that yeah yeah
there are there activities that we get
into the focusing of attention allows us
to
sometimes it's nice just to have
something else to concentrate on your
science is everything else going around
us that's why people like to doodle you
know drawing big sentences eventually
lot of us doodle sleeping I think that
was pretty easy if you don't sleep
you're gonna feeling pain as a result
how many of you like to hit the snooze
button that I'm kind of surprised
probably you know why when do you really
like hit the snooze button
there's probably two things I think one
is when you may actually got enough time
but it's not gonna cause you anxiety
right the other is when you really need
that sleep and you're really worn out
either because you've stayed up too late
or you're sick or because you did a lot
of physical exercise and you like to hit
that snooze button and get that extra
what is it minutes
watching sports that's an interesting
one every human society has some sort of
game or sports that they play we often
look down on sports and watching sports
as a merely you know an low-class
British not not very important kind of
activity but every civilization
developed something develop some sort of
activities that they don't just do
because they have to but because they
want to than some other people come
along to watch what do you get out of
watching sports yeah
and of course when they lose interest
the Greeks were really in the games and
they very often how these games in honor
yeah you would you know they were there
they're a lot of people who could run or
a lot of people who could box or a lot
of people who could you know do horse
racing and all these different kinds of
things that they would pick the best and
why did you pick the best because those
are actually more fun to watch we have
more enjoyments in watching excellent
competitors go against each other than
just watching anyway that's why we've
got higher ranking systems that's what
you know better teams have higher
attendance or better TV watch there is a
pleasure anything else second you watch
sports all by yourself usually yoga
there could be the element of friendship
is there a difference between watching a
sport where you really understand the
sport at all and what goes into making
something excellent and just sort of
showing up and attorney and is there a
difference in pleasure yes what's that
like what emulator sports you're gonna
watch the Super Bowl and really get a
lot out of it
what preconditions
oh these are these sort of things are
involving aspects that engage our
distinctively human inside more than
just our purity animal side I mean
animals like to watch things run around
cats like to watch you know birds fly
around little little children babies you
know what attracts them you give them
toys to play with that make noise or
rattle or that spin and they have to
talk things like that but watching
sports goes beyond that I'm not saying
that jon stewart go and say that this is
actually not super high but he probably
would still say you know reading and
cultivating your mind is always to be
preferred than to watching the game but
i think that we could actually see some
aspects of watching the game depending
on how you do it would engage your
higher faculties what about playing
sports maybe that's more of a just sheer
sheer modeling what do you think how
many of you play any sort of sport
during middle school high school or
college why would I be wrong to say uh
or just you know moving your body around
you like moving your body around and
that feels kind of good
what else did you get out of those are
you
else did you get out of it that made
that pleasure competition okay
okay so again it has to do with
something like friendship
maybe maybe companionship we like being
with other people who we share a common
pursuit method if you talk with
okay that's interesting so improvements
that would be distinctively there there
aren't any animals that measure
themselves against standards and say
here's what I want to achieve here's
what I need to do it or to get there let
me you know do it step by step by step
can you do that and when we do that we
feel a kind of sense of pride
accomplishment that's a pledge of higher
pleasure for us and no it's an extremely
important budget an ideal judge somebody
who's a good you know judge between
these kinds of pleasures is always going
to take the higher pleasure over the
lower pleasure and well because they
appreciate them so think about all these
don't think about other kinds of
pleasures contains that we have the real
test is what you would sacrifice against
what
well how you would rank these pleasures
we might be able to take some of these
with the add things to them and there
might make them get higher pleasures for
instance the watching sports so a lot of
us do like watching sports or let's say
it's not necessarily sports what are the
things that we can watch that we can
take enjoyment well you guys what
what else do you watch yeah
okay comedy that's a good example right
there maybe watch movies do you like
musical performances concerts what are
you getting think about the very low
level you know maybe you just like
action movies because things get blown
up if you like explosions that's not bad
that's probably a lower pleasure than
appreciating the interactions between
human beings in a drama or thinking
about you know funny situations funny
now imagine a sort of sort of higher
level you've actually been involved so
when you're listening to music I
remember for myself for example I
learned to play bass one of the things
that different is that made me
appreciate some bands a lot more and it
also made me appreciate something dance
a lot less up until that time I really
really like ac/dc and I still do like
ac/dc but I came to realize after
playing bass a while then just how
simple ac/dc songs are and that I could
basically you can actually play chords
on bass right
but I could play all these things
because these are three quart songs and
to do it just like that there were other
bands where because I had to dad and
experience I guess in wow that person is
really phenomenally good way you know
way beyond me and I could appreciate it
I could feel a pleasure tonight that
opened up sort of a door for me why was
that possible because I cultivated a
hired faculty to learn how to play
is not just you know picking it up and
removing fingers right
it's cultivating your mind if you want
to play baseball you have to learn some
music theory that's doing some mental
gymnastics what about sports do you
think it's the same for somebody who's
never played the sport to watch that as
somebody has to play that sport what
about the people who are commentators
you know those guys do you know they're
all you know suits and they're analyzing
it on Monday night why are they there
well what got them yeah they need to
know it inside and out and superb ly
they actually enjoy doing that it's not
just a way to make money and they have
been thinking about these things for
years and years and years why do we like
to watch them and listen to them there's
you know maybe maybe there's we know
that we should just get them along and
say shop you know morons let's watch the
game but we don't think that they're
wise we want to hear what they have to
say because they actually add to our
appreciation for the game when it comes
to movies if you actually like what
movie critics have to say if that if
learning about you know the ins and outs
of the movie improves your appreciation
of that movie you've not moved from a
fairly high level pleasure to get a
higher level pleasure and again Mill's
test for this what would an ideal judge
say would they if they were given the
choice okay watching the week and have
everybody shut up
don't tell you anything about the movie
and then afterwards state shut up or
watch the movie and then have somebody
who's knowledgeable about you know that
director and what they were doing and
why they film things this way and why
the narrative goes like that tell you
about all those things this is a higher
pleasure and if you're a good judge of
those budgets you will take that higher
pleasure in preference to the lower
budget every single time same thing with
food once you come to appreciate good
food let's take it on a I guess it's
probably a qualitative difference
think about fast food
Donald's Burger King you know all that
sort of stuff once you actually start
eating better food it's harder to go
back and eat McDonald's it doesn't taste
right I remember the experience for
myself I liked I liked a lot and then I
started cooking for myself a lot more
and I could make things healthier better
you know or savory and all that and then
to go back to a Burger King you know
it's just not satisfying now imagine the
next that's all still a sort of physical
pleasure now I need to take a gastronomy
class and you learn about the history of
that meal that you're you learn about
why it was set up that way who came up
with that recipe what the variations
were how people actually got angry or
excited or upset or envious I'm over
this dish which you can you know if you
go to the company to take classes you
will find out that food has its immense
rich history now that plate is put in
front of you and you have all these
associations they started hitting home
like so when you're eating that you're
not just tasting something
right that's a higher pleasure than just
to eat it and mill says again the ideal
judge the person who knows both the most
pleasures they're going to pick that
higher pleasure and they'll pick any
amount of that hybrid pleasure over any
amount of that lower pleasure so 30
meals at McDonald's versus one excellent
meal carried out by a guy at the
culinary if you actually know the
difference between those two kinds of
meals and you're a good judge of that
you will pick the culinary meal as
opposed to 30 or a hundred or a lifetime
supply of diamonds that's where we'll
leave on